yeah and then i guess finally is the
only japanese guy is maya de june uh he
basically his name sounds familiar yeah
he wrote music for like clan ad er he
also wrote clan he also wrote klein and
aaron cannon yeah and uh
yeah basically every key so basically
what makes miter journey is this because
you got into the the gacha recently
that's here
what makes my degen my [ __ ] idol is
just again the fact that this man can
single-handedly write a story write
characters and just write all the music
for it just single-handedly like it must
be an advantage though you can like
you know the characters in the story
better than anyone right you can craft
the whole what's but like i don't know
like
of course i like you know i i look up to
this guy just for like his ability to
like tell a story because like clan ad
and like air and cannon and angel beats
are like you know great stories right
yeah um but like i think the one thing
that makes my like i appreciate my agent
is just how [ __ ] musically talented
he is yeah because not only can he write
like somber like piano tracks that have
no lyrics at all like the entirety of
the clandestine soundtrack yeah make me
cry like a [ __ ] yeah i cried but he
can write [ __ ] bangers as well like
you know any of the angel beats songs
are like absolute [ __ ] like girl's
dead monster that like that fictional
band he created in angel beats every
song is a [ __ ] banger i'm like you
can write bangers and you can make me
cry it's pretty impressive i didn't know
that like how do you do that i didn't
know that and so like you were talking
about the gotcha game i got into so key
recently released a gacha game called
heaven burns red which is the first
fully mida jun produced game in 15 years
um and so he wrote the story is it a
visual novel uh it's a it's yeah it's
it's kind of like it's very dialogue
intensive because it's a [ __ ] game
yeah um
but it's also like it's like a
turn-based rpg kind of thing as well
okay of course it has gotcha so of
course you know yeah so he wrote the
story he wrote the character designs he
came up with the character designs
he came up with the scenario and he
wrote all the music for [ __ ] well
that's why he hasn't been doing anime
recently hasn't it exactly all this time
in uh i mean it's also because he's been
like extremely sick yeah as well oh man
like the whole like you know the whole
theme in like angel beats about like the
whole thing that's just based off his
own life oh jesus yeah because he has
like a chronic like heart uh like a
disease or something he's done so much
yeah yeah
i mean he wrote i'm pretty sure i don't
know if this is true but i think he
wrote angel beats in the hospital bed
seriously yeah while he was admitted to
hospital he wrote angels what the [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] bam and it's just yeah
and he's just like he's a banff like and
the fact that like again like this man
doesn't miss not like
he don't miss like every even in the new
game like the story is great the
characters are great and the music
[ __ ] slaps so i guess everything else
just lifts your enjoyment of the music
more right and it's like and i feel like
you know you know we were saying earlier
that like fully coolly as well right
like pillows i was i was very close to
putting pillows because that's just like
pinches it out for you yeah i think
mitogen just pinches it out for me
because like as much as i love the fully
cooling soundtrack the first soundtrack
that made me fall in love with anime
soundtracks was clannad
because like again as a pianist myself
listening to like piano music that makes
me [ __ ] break down crying
and it's like i can't even i can't even
like learn to play these songs without
crying right right and it's like that's
that's awesome and that's like really
hard to do as someone who like you know
because there's someone who writes music
i strive to do that to people right and
the fact that this guy can do it over
and over and over again with like
everything he also writes is like how do
you do that why can't one man have all
the talent okay it's not fair i'm just
saying
key would not be where they are without
this guy hey some sometimes you see
someone and you're like you're a bit too
talented
this is unfair and you're good looking
like yeah yeah as if i couldn't like
like
give me something to hate
god obviously didn't love all humans
equally because he made
it's not fair it's not fair i i wish i
had a sliver of the talent this guy has
yeah damn but uh yeah i guess that's my
three by three i was very uh i feel like
i learned a lot yeah learned i learned
way more than me talking myself or
listening to economics i don't know man
i i feel a little bit uh pushed back
because i was like i need to somehow top
gaunt living in anime backstory you
can't you can't top that i couldn't top
it so i was like the
i've been in like six bands but i never
had a cool story like i just i thought
when i said i was in a band everyone had
a similar experience
no no you're wrong why so what what
happened what normally happens when
you're in a band then do you not kind of
like pretend yeah yeah you go to the
drummer's house you play a couple of
cover songs that's it and then you're
like all right cool
see you never again yeah that happens
all the time
smash mouth once yeah what's the point
of forming a band if you're not going to
play gigs
how are you going to
how did you get a gig it's [ __ ] easy
in brighton there's so many oh yeah in
brighton yeah yeah in sydney it's pretty
[ __ ] difficult because there's no
whales this is fields
where am i going to sing all star can't
think about this there's like five gigs
going on every weekend and brian so i
guess i didn't take that i can't even
top you when it comes to like band names
either because like that band name is
just like [ __ ] like the best band name i
was in was resting [ __ ] face
but that's just because the lead singer
had a resting [ __ ]
it's always like that it's like cheeto
puffs
like it yeah it's kind of bad is in the
ass in 10 years and we have copyright
infringement yeah exactly let's just
deal with it but damn i guess that was
our trash taste in music yeah let us
know down below what you thought about
it and who has the trashiest taste
involved i've done me thank you very
much i appreciate that probably like i i
i had a hard time explaining why i liked
my music no you did not you [ __ ]
literally had amazing stories for
everything i i literally just like i did
like the thing is i didn't even talk
about the music that doesn't matter yeah
but you had like a kishimoto filler
artwork for stories for every single
baby